joining me live from beverly hills is
the real
wolf of wall street the author and
former stock broker jordan belf and of
course inspired the hollywood movie
wolf of wall street very warm welcome to
you and to
the program what do you make of all of
this
it's amazing that the average person
can now actually get a fair shake
since against the hedge funds because
the hedge funds have been beating up the
little investor for
since the beginning of time pretty much
and while this will be short-lived and
everyone's got to be really really
careful because it's going to be like
catching a falling knife when it
unravels
it's shocking and really amazing and
gratifying to see a little bit of this
the pain going on the side of the hedge
fund so that's my overall
you know personal opinion as far as you
know what's causing it and how it
started well
that's a much more complex issue and i
can answer that if you'd like as well
well let's just start with with your
point about it being quite gratifying
it's interesting you say that was there
a part of you given your own
background and your own success that
kind of admires this
well and believe it or not my firm was
actually like
reddit it's just that it was we were
it's very similar what happened here
is you have lots of people gathering up
and buying one stock
where there's a very heavy what's called
a short interest meaning that there was
these big hedge funds betting
that the stock was going to go down and
hopefully even go bankrupt now
shorting is a normal healthy part of the
stock market and it's important
but there are certain types of short
sales that
go over the line and they over short
they
massively short they will start trying
to create investigations for companies
create bad press hoping to drive down
the price of the stock
that is what happened here so these
these shorts ganged up on this company
and then the little guy i can't believe
that it actually worked
they were able to muster enough
collective buying power
to create what's called a short squeeze
because remember when you
sell something without owning it which
is what shorting is you got to buy it
back
so if you can get enough people to get
the stock going up
they have no choice but to buy it back
because they start to lose
so much money and then it becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy because when
they start to buy it back
it goes even higher and higher that's
what you're seeing happening right now
and so i detect from that then you do
admire it just you know the intelligence
behind it and i just wonder whether you
think this phenomenon is something that
we can expect to
persist that it might continue we've
seen haven't we as a result of lockdown
this
increase in in people kind of getting
involved in day trading perhaps with no
experience or background or really even
the funds
to to risk things but it's certainly on
the increase isn't it
i wish i would have thought of it myself
no it's really no it's an amazing thing
that you know anyone on wall street that
really knows wall street is like
i can't believe this was possible it
would seem to defy
logic at every level but it was really
incredible
it shows the power of social media
it's a testament to also the convergence
of technology
allowing even the smallest investor to
get real-time access to information
and the stock market and it's leveled
the field now the danger is that
wall street and hedge funds especially
are experts
at identifying what we call basically
inefficiencies in the market this is an
inefficiency in the market right now and
they will look to close that
inefficiency very quickly long before
the sec
or any other regulatory body is able to
pass laws to try to stop some of this
stuff that wall street will close the
inefficiencies
and you'll notice that these
opportunities become much
rarer indeed but again i'm on the side
of the little guy here because it's just
awesome to see and i really hope i would
just say please you know if you made
money in this
just take enough chips off the table so
when it goes bad
at least you didn't lose everything
because it's gonna go bad at some point
and i hate to be
the ones who are holding the bag that's
good advice it has to be said but i mean
it's interesting you say that you think
that you know
you're amazed that this was even
possible and you think that the loophole
will be tightened up but too slowly for
it to affect the guys here but
essentially
do you think that you know in terms of
the authorities that you know the
financial market authorities this is
a loose crime that we're talking about
okay so i hate to say but you're right
um it's illegal what they're doing
theoretically you can't collude together
to buy stock
right so that's really and that's by the
way what i said it was like a bit like
stratton my firm
that's what i was alluding to that it's
so much like what we were doing
except instead of having one firm doing
it it's all these individuals almost
acting like a firm together so i really
strongly doubt that any of them will get
in trouble what
they would get in trouble for one person
was driving it on got
long the stock early was buying lots of
stock and then
trying to create this frenzy that would
be something that the government would
certainly go after but in the other side
there's also some really questionable
behavior on the part of these trading
platforms
that are shutting down trading in this
now i understand that they have massive
risk as well so there is that
side where robin hood you know tends to
lose a stance lose a fortune
if the stock collapses and there are
losses in their clients accounts but the
way they did it
to restrict to shut trading down like
that at a moment's notice
they could have just as easily done
what's called raising the margin
requirement
meaning they make it very expensive to
buy stock
and that could have accomplished pretty
much the same thing so
why did they suspend trading like that
and i wonder
there are these relationships between
robin hood and the hedge funds who are
losing money
so that needs to be investigated as well
and all i can tell you is this i'd hate
to be the owner of robinhood because
i can't see how they survive this
because everybody and their grandma
is gonna sue robinhood and another
platform saying you shut down trading
you artificially caused me to lose money
whether they made money or lost money
robin's gonna be in robin who will be in
so many lawsuits class action suits that
i really does not bode well for their
future i mean it's
just impossible to overstate the
significance of this just based on what
you're telling me here and i just wonder
you know
whether you know on a broader scale if
we're actually looking at you know
almost on the edge of a sort of stock
market bubble here that we we could be
in a sort of difficult position
in the months to come you're hitting all
the right points here that's for sure so
yes i mean
this is 1999 all over again
and that's why i said i'm begging
everybody to please be careful here
i had someone fixing a tv in my house
yesterday and
the guy says oh my mother called me
she's 82 and she was asking me about
games i go by there you go
and and that's how it really gets bad
because you know when
when that last group of people start
getting in typically that's
they call it the odd lot theory that
when the average person gets in
that's the time it's going to actually
crash but again
you know you never know when that
moment's going to come it's going to
come of course because things will
eventually seek their fundamental value
but i would urge you again i just keep
saying because that you know
just it's a wonderful opportunity people
to make money everyone's bored and
locked up
but just be careful and make sure that
whatever you invest in these type of hot
stocks
make sure you invest only what you can
afford to lose and if you happen to make
money
pull the original investment out and
play with the house's money that's my
advice to everybody
and just lastly i'm assuming you didn't
get involved in this yourself that you
aren't kicking yourself but you haven't
been okay i'm kicking myself but i
didn't because
it was pretty obvious and i saw it like
i you you really hit
an important point like is there a crime
going on
theoretically you're not allowed to do
this i figure if i did it
i'd be the one they go after so i said
i'm better off staying like everyone
else will do it not get in trouble i'll
get in trouble
so i think it's probably best for me to
avoid these type of situations
but i would love i think it's really
important that the people who are doing
this at least learn
about the actual stock market because
it's really
great they should be financially
literate the info is out there
be careful and make money
and and whilst you're being so honest
and urging us all to make money just
finally because i can't let you go
you're being such an interesting
guest any tips on how we can do that as
someone who is actually financially
illiterate
yes yes so number one there are a few
things i could tell you without
giving you any particular stocks number
one at this
point i would say gamestop is is over in
other words
the ride is gone so you're at that point
now remember ultimately what's gonna
happen is is that all of these
stocks that are involved in short
squeezes they'll eventually trade as a
basket
they'll go up and down together at any
one time because there's only so much
hot money that can flow into these
stocks so they
go up they go down almost in tandem
after a while
the key is number one is if you can try
to if you really want to do this
you want to you know stay on these
message boards you can try to really
find out what the next one that they're
talking about is and get in
right early towards the beginning so
there's an old saying on wall street
bulls make money bears make money pigs
get slaughtered
you don't want to catch the bottom and
you don't want to catch the top
try to get it at the beginning of the
end and the uh
at the end of the beginning and get out
at the beginning of the end don't try to
top ticket don't try to bottom ticket
try to get that little middle and don't
be
greedy it's it's it's i know even if
you're not a greedy person
it's this weird human nature that
develops that
we just we see this easy money and you
know we all want to believe in santa
claus
so we stay in longer than we should
versus saying you know what i did really
well i should just be happy
let me use this money and buy something
for myself my family give something to a
charity whatever don't just like try to
keep making this
you're still gonna have a real living
and go to work and make money don't
try to do this as something that's going
to replace your job because it's not
going to last forever but it's a
wonderful way to keep busy now
and make some good money as long as
you're careful that's one way
i would really do is just don't be
greedy and try to get in at the
beginning not at the end
okay as soon as there's a bandwagon
you're not onto a good thing really good
advice i'm trying to write all of this
down
jordan belfort real pleasure to talk to
you thanks so much the original
wolf of wall street my pleasure take
care